good evening members and offices of the
council and members of the press and
public I welcome you to this
extraordinary meeting of the council if
the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs I have
through the security doors to my right
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in holy square on the green
offices will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber the Proceedings of this meeting
will be recorded and subsequently
broadcast on the internet I would advise
that if filming takes place anyone in
attendance in the public areas may have
their image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
any members of the public who object to
the possibility of being filmed may wish
to take this opportunity to leave the
meeting any filming or recording will
not be permitted for any item of
business where exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the press and public from
the meeting would everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned to silent and they are not
used to make or receive phone calls in
the chamber while this meeting is in
progress
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councillors crow brown current Jeremy
Fairbrass Lin Fabrice Gary Hillman
Welles and Glenn Coleman cook are there
any other apologies
agenda item two announcements I have not
been informed of any announcements
agenda item three declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest agenda item four election of
leader of the council are there any
nominations council savage thank you
madam chair
as he's the leader the largest group in
this chamber this evening I propose
councillor Bob Baffert
is there a seconder
Thank You chairman I'd like to second
counselor Beauford councillor Campbell
Thank You chair yes oh great pleasure I
would like to nominate to councillor
Karen Constantine it's not a seconder
it's about I'm sure I'd like to second
that
are there any other nominations
I would like to request a show of hands
those in favor of counselor Beaufort
please raise your hand
the point of all the chair I was in
consultation with mr. house who assured
me that there would be candidates will
be allowed to wait make a small speech
for three minutes
with those who favor accounts to
Constantine please raise your hands
I declare that counselor Beaufort has
been elected leader of the council until
the council elections in May 2000 and 19
I call upon the leader thank you
it's for me to nominate my deputy and
that's going to be counselor Jason
Savage what one I'm standing up I would
just like to thank council constant time
for a very clean contest what wonder the
fairest I've been involved in and I
would like to thank Council for
entrusting the conservative group to
take this council forward I believe that
we're going to do a great job and we're
very pleased with our performance over
the coming years there's obviously going
to be a lot of challenges but I think
ratchet we've got a very experienced
team and it would be my intention very
shortly to produce our program of work
that we expect to carry out in becoming
14 months normally when you take control
of account so you've got four years in a
majority we've got fourteen months and a
significant minority so the challenges
are going to be tough but I really do
believe we're up to it and we've proved
that thank you
I declare that council Savage has been
elected it has been appointed deputy
leader of the council until the council
elections in May 2009 teen I call upon
the monitoring officer Thank You
chairman there are just two procedural
matters needed clarification from there
from the new leader firstly I imagine
you've yet to decide on the division of
cabinet responsibilities so can I have a
confirmation that the present portfolio
holders job descriptions remain the same
for the time being happy to confirm that
thank you
and the second matter chairman Issa I'm
clear we have a schema delegations in
place which is a servant by the leader
can the leader please agree that the
present scheme should continue until
amended by him
so confirmed that concludes the business
for this extraordinary meeting of the
council Council Johnson sorry I'm
congratulations to councilor Beaufort
and I'm just wondering if he has any
intention of nominating somebody else to
be chair of Council and vice chair of
Council thank you so that the chair and
vice chair council is not within the
gift of the leader that's within the
gift of the council I'm sorry but
actually and they usually the ruling
group nominates their choice and then it
goes to a vote I'll repeat again the
appointment of chair and vice-chair
house is not within the gift of the
leader it's through the gift of the
council thank you counts for constant
time can I just make a point of order oh
sorry
can I make a point of order please can I
just put on the record that I'm actually
very disappointed that there wasn't the
opportunity to make short speeches I
think it's in the interest of local
democracy to do that thank you
your point of order is no to Council
Constantine and that concludes the
business for this extraordinary meeting
of the council